[Music]
I'm gonna fight you because nobody's
fine now we're good I so joke do you
like sports things such as physical
features you get it yeah really get it
let's go all right I got you now we're
the hell do you shop at short and small
because that got to be a little boy
launch yeah that was the obvious one all
right if I gotta do this all just uh
cube your mama what is it which sit by
my mama all right how's your mom doing
she good
what's this for you know I mama Baga
you mean Mme take off the pad oops
thanks joke's on you pal
okay I'm not going right for your nuts
now suggest you do something like this
yeah oh no that's cool can you show me a
move where I choke him out any done
itself yup how crowd Roy we're gonna
crown yeah buddy gonna see is he gonna
just act like a bitch the whole time are
you guys like a business busy you made
me a fan now this man make me your fan
no I don't want me to fight I'll act
like a bitch fine no that's not how you
get the crowd so you gotta be who want
to see me look bad oh no I got the crowd
I should just put my foot right in your
ass that's confident that's important
too
[Music]